what's your favorite color rainbow oh
that's nice how do you like school do
you like school in Miami yes good are
you having fun today yeah are you gonna
go play outside and look at the player
outside but the good eat something just
like their dark side oh you're gonna eat
something and lie down in the sun yeah
ooh that's fun you want to go play
there's Scarlet
[Music]
hello and welcome to my channel I'm
Michaela Peterson if you've been
watching my channel for a while or my
podcast you may notice I look slightly
different it's because I was sitting
extremely close to the camera and the
focal length was at about 25 and now
it's at like
50 60 something like that so this is
actually what I look like in person I
don't look like
the fish from Pinocchio I've been
wondering what was going on for about a
year every time I looked at a clip I was
like oh like something was off with my
nose not entirely sure talked to my
husband about it I was like we need to
fix this something's weird with my
camera I do like 12 other things other
than the podcast so it wasn't my primary
concern I was just kind of avoiding
looking at myself on video anyway focal
length was off
this is me so I'm gonna do a q a here we
go I asked my Instagram audience for
questions so I'm just picking randomly
from questions that were asked on
Instagram if you weren't creating
podcasts what would you be creating I
actually don't spend very much time
podcasting I got so busy with other work
last year that I dropped my podcast from
twice a week to once a week I think it
was last October I'm actually going to
be going back to twice a week in January
doing in-person podcasts so that should
be a ton of fun we have a studio in
Miami now and I'm really looking forward
to that if I wasn't creating podcasts
what would I be doing so what I
currently do is I spend probably 60 of
my time maybe 70 of my time managing my
dad's brand I started the social media
dad started his own YouTube channel way
back in the day and Twitter everything
that he's doing I've set up a team and
oversee that team that eats up most of
my time because he's doing so many
different things and I want to make sure
people experience him online like he is
in real life there's a lot of
misinformation to counter I also manage
PR so that's mostly what I do now and
then we're starting this Peterson
Academy which is launching next year
which is massive and I'm insanely
excited about it uh that's where I'll be
also filming my podcast so we have a
studio we're going to be bringing
professors in from all over the world
top professors to film eight hour
lecture content to put on Peterson
Academy we're building in a social media
element that's kind of like Reddit and
Instagram people will be able to DM each
other and form study groups and watch
lectures and comment on the lectures and
take notes there isn't an app out there
like this we're going to be launching
late next year so I'm spending a good
portion of my time managing that project
basically what happened was my dad's had
this idea for an online university for a
very long time and we put out a course
dad's personality course in 2018 and
that was massively successful so I was
like okay Dad should be doing more
courses that's what he should be doing
the books but he should really be doing
the courses other than the podcast and
so last year I thought we can do our own
courses right we don't need another
company we can have our own production
company and make our own courses but
couldn't we also make courses for other
people and couldn't we give people who
deserve a platform more of a platform
and so the idea kind of sprang out of
that last year and then since last year
it's kind of morphed into well Dad
wanted to build an online university I
kind of want to make courses for people
let's combine that and now we have an
app in production we're going to be
filming like 60 courses in the next year
for Peterson Academy I'm so excited it's
going to be massive I think we can
transform education I think we can make
education accessible to everyone I think
we can start to fight back against the
massive scam that is particularly
American universities the amount of
money that students are charged to take
courses from ideologically possessed
professors to leave them with a degree
that doesn't lead to a job to teach them
that capitalism is evil and the reason
they're in debt and don't have a job is
because of capitalism
and corporate greed even though they
just overcharge for a University degree
you can't use it's just a it's such a
scam and so I think it would be really
funny to get professors from like Oxford
and Cambridge and Stanford and U of T
and MIT and these massive universities
really top-notch professors and then
produce really beautiful courses try to
make the courses entertaining because
you can learn from podcasts you don't
have to sit in a stuffy classroom and
learn from a professor anymore you can
learn from podcasts now so why why can't
you get a degree from education you can
learn from this entertaining online like
why can't you do that you should be able
to do that there's a huge niche as
someone who loves jewelry but also
values long-term investment and doesn't
trust the dollar I was totally thrilled
when I discovered Monet their selection
of Pier 24 karat gold in platinum
jewelry not only looks beautiful I have
this guy
but it also maintains its value and
potentially even appreciates over time
depending on the value of gold each
piece essentially a wearable bullion
ensuring that its value is never in
doubt they also provide a lifetime
guarantee to buy back or exchange any
Monet jewelry at the prevailing gold and
platinum market prices minus 10 and
because each piece is made of solid gold
or platinum it's essentially an
investment you can wear it's actually
worth what you pay for it as opposed to
some other jewelry companies you're
basically buying gold and platinum
customers can see the price of each
piece change in real time based on the
live gold price and contract the value
of their jewelry just like a stock in
their Monet account it's very cool and
some of them look really good and they
have rings for men as well but it's cool
you can just buy gold solid 24 karat
gold it's like it's a different color
than normal jewelry and you can wear
that so that's cool you can get five
percent off with code MP if you go to
Monet that's
m-e-n-e.com so if you're still looking
for last minute Christmas gifts or you
just want to buy jewelry that's actually
worth something check out monet.com you
can get sweet things like this or like I
said rings necklaces earrings very cool
mini.com m-e-n-e.com code MP for five
percent off buy jewelry that is worth
what you pay for it so that's partly
what I'm doing and then also I've got my
the lion diet part of my brand and I
focus on that because I'm currently on
that diet ruminant meat salt and water
my parents are on that diet for
autoimmunity and severe food allergies
to everything and I would not even be
close to where I am I wouldn't I
wouldn't be able to get out of bed
if I wasn't on this diet so part of the
money I make from the advertising that I
do on my podcast I put towards spreading
information about the lion diet for free
if people are interested in that I've
got a ton of information at liondiet.com
and I did a key q a for my five-year
lion diet experience which I will link
right here and I'm launching a hangover
pill that I've been talking about off
and on on my podcast for a while called
after party drinking on a carnivorous
diet leaves you with a hangover from
hell I used to get bad hangovers before
I started dieting and now they're on a
different level so I use this hangover
pill which is it's fine it's
dihydramaricetin it helps you break down
acetaldehyde which is the toxic
byproduct of alcohol so you ingest
alcohol it works weekly on Gaba
receptors while people aren't exactly
sure how it works but it seems to work
on Gaba receptors which is why it makes
you feel calm and relaxed and kind of
giggly and your body desperately tries
to break it down because it's toxic and
it starts producing acetaldehyde and
dihydramy-racetin helps people break
down acetaldehyde more rapidly and
they've done studies on rats that are
conclusive that this works so I'm
launching that as well hey guys I wanted
to pop in to say after party is now
available I know I talked about it in
this episode it is now available at
smartdrugs.life I tried really hard to
get it out before New Year's it has a 30
day money back guarantee so you can try
it and if you don't like it you can get
your money back but I'm confident if you
take it properly
two pills before bed two to three pills
before bed and two in the morning you
will never go back it's way healthier
than just drinking helps you detoxify
the alcohol and not suffer as many
repercussions and like I said I tried
hard to get it out before New Year's if
you order it before the 26th it should
come before New Year's and you can use
code MP for 15 off and that's at
smartdrugs.life drink smart and enjoy
okay next was it hard to divorce
considering what your dad talks about
yeah actually it was and this is an
interesting topic so I grew up believing
that if marriages failed it was because
you didn't know how to negotiate that's
kind of what I grew up believing was if
marriages broke down it was because the
people in the marriages didn't know how
to negotiate I don't believe that
anymore after going through what I went
through I don't want to get into details
but you can also just have people that
are not compatible at all I have no
difficulty negotiating and I think if I
had known
that
some people are just incompatible
and that
and if I had been told it's better to
get a divorce
than to spend years fighting and like
suffering really in a relationship
that's not good for anybody
uh I would have got divorced sooner and
I think that would have been better for
everybody I also don't like this kind of
and I think it's more in the red pill
Community or right-wing community that
women are basically blamed for the
divorce epidemic they're like oh 70 of
divorces are initiated by women
it and in the red pill Community it's
kind of like it's funny and the
conservative Community it's like it's
women's fault and in the liberal
Community it's men's fault my theory is
everyone's crazy now that makes
relationships very difficult so yes I
guess the answer to that question was it
was very very difficult to get divorced
considering what my dad talks about it
made me stay in a relationship longer
than I should have I don't agree with
the more conservative
story of divorce that people are being
told I think being in a relationship
that's not good for you I think you
should get out of that relationship
because
the like Jordan my current husband
he's amazing he's amazing
I have never felt this good before in my
entire life
hey we can negotiate he doesn't take
anything I say personally I which makes
me
which allows me to communicate right
because I don't feel like I'm going to
hurt anybody's feelings it's fantastic
so just because like if you're in
a shitty relationship
and it's killing you don't think that
you're just the problem next how many
children do I want okay this is fun I
think children are amazing I
particularly like them when they're a
little bit older I'm not as much of a
baby person but I know my relationship
with my parents now I think above the
age of 23 was just fantastic and I
really want that when I'm old so I think
I would like
probably like four more kids it's a lot
of kids five kids in total however and I
might get some hate for this but I don't
care I probably won't carry all of those
kids and the reason for that is it
depends I guess how my pregnancy my next
pregnancy goes so I'm
and I can't tell you how
much this is true but I'm petrified of
being depressed again when I get
pregnant so with Scarlet my depression
came back and I've spent my entire life
trying to fight my way out of depression
which is why I'm on like only eating
meat and salt and water like I have
tried everything to get rid of
depression and I'm not depressed I'm
doing fantastic and I'm petrified that
the pregnancy hormones are going to make
me depressed and if I'm depressed then
I'm less productive and if I'm less
productive than all these projects I'm
doing will at least slow down or at
least they'll feel like they're falling
apart they won't necessarily fall apart
but they'll feel like they're falling
apart
um when Peterson Academy launches I'll
have a hard time
promoting it if I'm depressed during
pregnancy and Pregnant anyway as you can
tell I'm extremely concerned about this
I've literally been praying about it
like please
please don't bring the depression back
if I get pregnant when I get pregnant if
I have a you know the end of pregnancy
is hard on women period that's fine it's
just I don't want to be hit with
pregnancy hormones and go crazy as soon
as it happens and then not be able to
work because not working kills me so if
the pregnancy goes well then I will be
having a bunch of children if the
pregnancy doesn't go well though and I
get depressed and by depressed I don't
mean anxious I mean like suicidal
because I don't I don't get like anxious
depressed I get like I'm gonna punch
holes in walls and jump out a window
depressed and if that happens I'm going
to be
egg harvesting and getting a surrogate
because I'm not just because my brain is
weird when and it's definitely weird I'm
on this diet to stay sane doesn't mean I
don't want to have kids plus I guess the
benefit of a surrogate too would be I
think some of these allergic diseases
which I have in my family are passed on
through the birth canal you inherit a
lot of your microbiome from your mother
and so maybe if I also didn't have the
kid
they wouldn't
have the same kind of allergic disorder
that I have
it's a theory it's not a bad Theory so
anyway that's my answer to having
children I do want more children I
really hope I don't grow crazy during
pregnancy how do you handle getting
targeted negatively for being
conservative I don't really care
about what
anybody including news sources say
online about me
anymore also jokes on you guys I'm
actually not conservative I would say I
like the temperament of conservatives
better than the average temperament of
liberals I think it's harder to
offend them which is satisfying you know
it's easier to communicate with people
that aren't just like oh how could you
say that all the time but
I'm not particularly conservative I just
kind of want the government to leave
people alone so I'm libertarian I'm
probably libertarian to the right a
little bit I don't think I'm
particularly conservative I don't really
like anybody
whatever that political party is ooh you
and your husband met and married very
fast you advise this for most people
no I don't definitely not so we met in
Austin and we really got along like
really really got along and I flew back
to Toronto and like maybe a week and a
half after that so two and a half weeks
after meeting him he told me over the
phone he wanted to marry me
and I almost I was driving I almost died
I was like are you it's like first of
all
you're younger than me I'm 30. he's 25.
it's like you're quite a bit younger
than me that seems to pose a problem
second like I work all the time
so in order for this to work you're
gonna have to work all the time
we're gonna have to work together we're
already working together and I had met
him and I knew that he was conscientious
so that helped I was like we're gonna
have to work all the time I was like
also I have a child I have a child
so there is a child I also have an
ex-husband like that's not going away
that's a continual
relationship
anyway I listed a whole bunch of
problems and he was like yeah I know
it's like okay well that worked for me
because I'd met him and
I'd already been like I knew what worked
for me and I'd never met anybody like
him exactly and so I knew that was going
to work for me I don't advise it for
most people however I also don't advise
waiting 13 years
what is that about I feel like I feel
like two years is reasonable two and a
half years is reasonable like you have
the honeymoon period of a year
um I have now known Jordan for
a year and a half so I'm over the
honeymoon period still very much in love
with him so that's a relief but I think
at the two-year period of like dating
somebody you've passed through the
honeymoon period and then you could get
married then at least get engaged I
think two years is like plenty of time
um maybe under a year is a little
soon because there's that first kind of
nine months of honeymoon period where
you don't necessarily argue or know each
other very well so no for most people I
wouldn't recommend that but also if
you've been dating somebody for four
years and you're like well just need to
get to know them a little bit better and
then maybe we'll get a dog like guys
you're gonna die at some point maybe
hurry it up
especially if you want kids and if you
don't want kids you should want kids
because what are you gonna do when
you're old who's gonna take care of you
I'm taking care of my parents I'm a very
helpful daughter
if I do say so myself I feel like that's
what when kids are are useful is when
like above the age of 20 and then they
can have their own little families you
can have grandkids and stuff why
wouldn't you want that next encouraged
by your posts kicking meds are you still
taking any prescriptions no I can't take
any prescription medication really
without experiencing all the side
effects listed on the label that's the
insert in the bottle right so I can't
take any antihistamines I can I can take
certain painkillers as long as they
don't have any preservatives super
allergic to sodium metabisulfite which
is in almost every painkiller in America
I can't take those I can take Tylenol
kind of and I can take this after party
pill isn't that convenient although I
wouldn't be selling it if I couldn't
take it and I don't take any
prescriptions anyway no because I get
severe side effects right as soon as I
came off of psych meds I came off of
psych meds when I was 23 for those of
you who don't know me complaining about
the pharmaceutical industry and how
dangerous psych meds are came off when I
was 23 and since then I really haven't
been able to take any
prescriptions without experiencing
severe side effects like crawling
Sensations all over my body and extreme
volatility like anger like punching
walls angry and uh Doom
irritability a lot of Psych symptoms
sometimes I get hives on my arms so
I don't take any prescriptions
favorite clothing brand I really like
arizia they have plain clothing so most
of my stuff's from origin I'm wearing
sweatpants right now on the bottom from
aritzia and then I really like balmaine
for the bougie brand I like balmaine I
think they have very cool clothes how's
your sleep has it improved mom of a nine
month old and everything wakes me up no
I am mum of a five-year-old and
everything wakes me up I don't I think
as soon as you have a kid as a mom
it just damages your brain into never
being able to sleep again I have to
sleep with white noise so I sleep with
like my phone next to my ear on airplane
mode
for all of you health nerds out there
but I I actually sleep with it on
airplane mode so that I don't get phone
calls but anyway white noise and a mask
I use this mask that doesn't squish
these eyelashes actually it's gotten
it's gotten intense now my sleeping
routine it's like yesterday I put my
hair in this weird I saw it on Tick Tock
ugh I was on Tick Tock for for a day it
was horrible anyway it wasn't a whole
day it was a little bit of time it was
awful but I did see this um
thing that you can wrap your hair around
make it curly so that it's not damaging
so I had like my hair curled and I had
like nose tape on so my nose doesn't get
puffy in the morning and then I had my
eye things on and my white noise that's
how I sleep
what's your biggest goal of 2023 and
what is your smallest so my biggest goal
is successfully launching Peterson
Academy
and my smallest goal
is getting my sleep schedule on track
because Jordan the introduction of
Jordan into my life has severely
negatively impacted my sleep
I feel the best when I go to sleep at 10
30 and I wake up at 6 30 and I've been
going to sleep at like 12 30 or 1 and
it's just been terrible for productivity
for me feeling good
for overall health and well-being so my
smallest goal would be shift in that
bedtime backwards back to 10 30. what
would you tell young women as their role
model I really look up to you smiley
face that's cute I would say
don't sleep around it just hurts that's
coming from somebody who you know had
experiences in University that hurt so
don't do that just because everyone else
is doing it doesn't mean you have to do
it it doesn't make you
better it doesn't make men want you more
if anything it works in in the opposite
way so don't do that and work on
yourself watch educational podcasts read
books learn how to do something and get
your diet in order get your sleep
schedule on track exercise there you go
do all those things and then you'll find
somebody because you'll be sane and also
don't take birth control it makes you
crazy
how is your current relationship with
God that's an intense question uh I
don't know I think it's good I think
there's more that I could be doing I was
reading the Bible more a year ago
and then since my sleep schedule kind of
went off track I stopped waking up as
early and then I stopped reading the
Bible in the morning so I should work on
that because I did feel better reading
the Bible more seems weird I know to all
you people who aren't Christian that
sounds strange it was strange to me too
it's still strange to me I don't know
how it works exactly but it makes me
feel better and I haven't been doing it
very often I've been doing it but not
very often so I should work on that but
I'm trying to I'm trying to go
with the flow you know when you're
trying to make something happen and
nothing is working for you I'm trying to
avoid things like that so if things
don't work out that I want to work out
I'm thinking well maybe that's not meant
to be maybe God doesn't want that for me
so I've been trying to operate like that
and it's
been good for me I think because I like
to exert a level of control over
everything that isn't good for me or the
things around me and so I've let that go
a little bit what are your thoughts on
gluten I don't think anyone should eat
gluten I think there's a lot of evidence
that it contributes to gut permeability
in everyone not just people with celiac
disease so you shouldn't eat it because
it causes gut damage and even the you're
like oh well maybe maybe you only eat
sourdough bread
maybe it's the super healthy sourdough
bread there's still evidence that the
gluten in sourdough bread that's made in
the old-fashioned way damages your gut
so my thoughts on gluten is everyone
should cut out gluten right now and they
would feel better I'm that person around
my friends you're eating a donut then I
give them the stare
of judgment
like don't bring it into my house I have
celiac disease I don't want any donut in
my house but it's true don't get that
crumb on me I don't know what'll happen
go crazy
can we see your forehead more often you
imprison it way too much what did it
ever did do to you so here's my forehead
look at it exposed for a while there
I thought my forehead was too big and
I've decided it's not too big
thing is too too fat too too long I
thought it was too long for a long time
being female is hard for everybody
anyway it's like my forehead's too big I
need bags so then I had bangs for a long
time and then this year it was worth
like oh my forehead's so big but that
was partly because the focal length was
too short on my camera so it was like
stretching my face out making my nose
bigger and like my upper lip bigger and
my forehead a little bit bigger so now
my
I'm trying the no bangs look what did it
do to me it didn't do anything to me I
just thought it was too big and then I
changed my mind this episode is brought
to you by nordvpn I went back to visit
family in Canada and it's still crazy
there I just turned my dad onto nordvpn
keeping your information away from
prying eyes including the government
particularly if you're in Canada is a
silly thing to not do in this day and
age it's way easier than it was 10 years
ago and you can basically turn nordvpn
on to run in the background and forget
it's there nordvpn has award-winning
online security so you can be confident
knowing that you won't be exposed to any
prying internet eyes or have your
personal information leaked to people
who might use it against you just go to
nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature as well as
nordvpn's 30-day money-back guarantee
what's your educational background okay
so my educational background I went to
Concordia and Montreal which is
basically the school that people go to
if they don't get into Mcgill and I had
my hip and Ankle replaced when I was 17.
so I missed about a year of high school
and in order to make up that year it was
a huge pain I missed the last half of
one year and the first half of the next
year so it screwed up two years of high
school for me and I hated high school
and in order to get all the Sciences I
would have had to stay in high school
for two extra years and at that point I
didn't know that you could just take
courses online I just didn't know that
so I was like well I'm not going to
catch up on Sciences I'll just go into
Arts anyway I had a good average out of
high school I think I had a 93 average
out of high school it's good average but
I didn't get into the program I wanted
to at McGill so I went to Concordia for
psychology and a minor in Classics and I
did that for two years and I got
unbelievably sick and dropped out and I
was so sick year two I gained about I'm
123 pounds right now now I was 145
pounds so I'd gained 20 pounds in two
years and
um
I was mostly surviving off of Mr Noodles
and beer and pizza there's a pizza place
right around the corner for me and I was
going crazy and I couldn't get out of
bed like I couldn't move and I was very
very sick so I dropped out I didn't even
go to my final second year I remember
trying to get out of bed and being like
I can't do it and I'm not somebody who
does that I thought I was
for a while I thought that everyone had
a really really hard time getting out of
bed and I was just lazy I thought that
for a really long time that wasn't true
I was like deathly ill anyway so I did
two years of that then I went to make up
school because I thought I wanted to be
a makeup artist because one of the
things that helped me survive through
the hip and ankle replacement was
putting on makeup because it was like
okay I I feel like I'm gonna die I'm in
chronic pain and putting on makeup at
school made me feel like I could survive
so I was like oh I want to become a
makeup artist and then I can help people
you know feel like they want to survive
so I did that for about three months and
I was like oh my gosh this is my dad was
so not impressed my mom was like do what
your heart feels and my dad was like
you're gonna hate it and this is a bad
idea
and I was like what do you know Dad and
so I went to make up school anyway and
he was right and about three months into
it I was like I'm going to die of
boredom and I wasn't on a diet I was I
was taking Adderall at that point to
wake up and get out and I went back to
school after that I got all my high
school Sciences when I was when I was 22
which was that was a whole thing that's
very frustrating to have to do that it's
like well back in high school
you're joking so I went back and got my
high school scientists sciences and then
I started taking night school for
biomedical science degree so that I
could get good enough grades to get into
the day school program then I got into
the day school program for biomedical
science and I went into biomedical
science because
I was in makeup school and my wrist was
like not working my right hand and I
went to my rheumatologist and I was like
I think
I think maybe I'm gonna need my wrist
replaced because this was a this was
quite a bit of pain I was taking
painkillers at night to sleep on my
shoulders because my shoulders hurt and
I'd already had my hip and Ankle
replaced and he goes not this is a good
rheumatologist in Toronto too he goes
joint Replacements are very rare
it's like not really I have two like
what that's what's gonna make me feel
better they're very rare they're not
rare for me they're fairly common for me
and so my wrist hurt like I couldn't
lean on my arm to bring myself out of a
chair or or anything and even just doing
fine motor movements like I used to do
my exams for instance when I went into
biomedical science
um I used to do them in a special like
disability room that people now take
advantage of so that I could type
because I couldn't write out the essays
because of my wrist anyway so I went
into biomedical science and I thought
I'd need to get a PhD in microbiology or
Immunology to figure out my autoimmune
disorder and two years into that degree
I came across you know I was researching
the medications I was on and how the
immune system works and I was taking
cell biology and things like that and
um I figured out the rash that I had was
a Celiac disease rash called dermatitis
herpetiformis you guys might know this
part of the story
that is my life and um I started going
down the diet route and then the diet
just paleo diet like simplified very
restrictive paleo diet just fixed me
it's like
okay maybe I don't need a PhD then what
are these food allergies what's going on
then I went off of antidepressants when
my
when my arthritis went away and my skin
healed when I went on the paleo diet and
then [ __ ] got real so
um I was in school suffering a lot
throughout the antidepressant withdrawal
trying to reintroduce foods to figure
out what I was allergic to hallucinating
occasionally from the antidepressant
withdrawal
and then like Midway through the
antidepressant withdrawal I got pregnant
and that was scarlet and
then
my life kind of like blew up I ended up
with a baby so that's cool but uh that's
also at the same time Dad got famous
and so I got pregnant I finished
what was I taking
organic chemistry and Immunology during
pregnancy and then I started working for
Dad when I had
Scarlett I started working for dad
because he had all this opportunity and
he needed help like organizing podcasts
and capitalizing on the opportunity that
was presenting
itself to him and I was like well
this seems like something I should jump
on I'm gonna help and so I didn't go
back to school and he was like well are
you gonna go back to schools like well
do you want me to go back to school or
do you want me to help you because
I can't do the job I'm doing which was
growing social media managing events I
like hired a different book agent hired
a touring agent because the people who
he was working with were gouging him so
I like restructured all that
and
I didn't go back to school because one I
had put my autoimmune disorder in to
remission which is why I wanted to go to
school in the first place and two I was
making money and three some of the
things I was learning in school didn't
line up with what I was learning from
scientific articles online
right try taking nutrition in schools
like well that's not true it's like ah I
don't want to pass tests by lying so I
took two years of biomedical science and
two years of psychology and Classics and
I have no degree but maybe with the
launch of Peterson Academy I'll just get
a degree from there wouldn't that be
funny how's your book coming along so
I've been working on this book since I
was 17. writing is part of what kept me
sane through the hip and ankle
replacement and like chronic illness if
I was angry I wrote down I've been
keeping a journal since grade one so I
have this Memoir that I've been writing
forever I've taken a bit of a pause
because I'm a bit traumatized from what
happened to Dad I had PTSD
from hospitals which is something that
you can get
so I had that
and I was managing that and trying to
desensitize Myself by like exposing
myself to hospitals
um and then Dad and Mom got sick and it
was like oh I have to go into these
places in order to visit them
and then I took care of dad for two
years and it was the worst experience of
my entire life the amount of suffering
he had was
unbearable
to watch
you know that um scene in Harry Potter
when they're showing the cruciatus curse
to the bug
that's what Dad looked like for two
years
so
um I'm still
processing that and so if I get too
stressed or if I stay up too late then I
start having flashbacks of like Russian
Hospital
Serbian Hospital
stupid Canadian hospital and I've
written like one draft of what happened
but I haven't gone back and edited it
because I'm stressed out about it still
but I feel like I'm almost able to do
that so I I woke up this morning for
instance I'm I woke up too early and
then I was awake in bed and I was just
like revisiting what's happened over the
last number of years
and I need to get this book out of me
desperately it's torturing me and I need
to write down all these memories so that
I can put them in a nice little Memoir
and then get it out of me and so that's
still gonna happen I think maybe March
I'll sit down for a month and just
solidly write I have way more than I
need for a book already and I haven't
even written the last couple of years
and I kept wanting to finish the book
but I couldn't finish it because it was
like hey I had an autoimmune disorder
and then I found this crazy diet that
nobody believes although some people
believe it it's working for them and
then my dad got famous and and now he's
really sick the end like I couldn't end
it or now I'm in the middle of a divorce
the end and it just wasn't
a good story so I kept waiting for my
life to
in my family's lives to sort themselves
out
so that the Memoir has a good heading
and it has a good ending right now so I
should write it real quick
maybe in March
I'm gonna call it could be worse
because that's what I told myself a lot
when I was suffering
well
it's bad but it could be worse I don't
know why that made me feel better Dad
hated that how much of marriage is about
predetermined compatibility and how much
is about effort
so this is one of those things that kept
me in a marriage I shouldn't have been
in for too long
ah it shouldn't be constant effort I
don't believe that
I don't think it should be constant
effort it should almost all be about
predetermined compatibility there are
people you get along with and there are
people you don't if you marry one of
those people you don't get along with
how much effort can you push into that
to make it work
so predetermined compatibility there's
also this interesting study that I just
read about on Twitter the other day and
then I read the actual study that was
off of Twitter and they did I'm just
going to butcher this but they did
fmri's
to monitor brain waves
oh my gosh
I'm gonna have to find it I'm just gonna
butcher it they just they found out that
it wasn't just personality traits that
made you attracted to somebody you had
similar brain waves so the vibe thing
that I've been talking about a little
bit about if you're around someone you
get a good vibe that's a real thing
so I used to ignore Vibes and ignore
intuition
because I thought that that wasn't
scientific or something ridiculous
instead of understanding that I'm
picking up on things that maybe I can't
verbalize but they're real anyway I'm
gonna put a screenshot of that study up
here
and then you guys can read it if you
want it's very interesting I understand
myself results don't
reflect myself at all can I take it
again so
I've been doing you know running the
marketing teams for my dad's Brands as
well and he's got these two products
um whoop he's got these two products
understand myself and self-authoring
very useful products can be very helpful
for people and not understand myself
it's like only take this once
I was like that's the worst sales pitch
I have ever heard don't put only take
this once on the website dad
it
you could sell it multiple times anyway
I personally have taken that probably
eight times
um over the period of my life before it
was understand myself.com you had to
manually score your personality
I used to give those to people I dated
and then add up their personality traits
be like you're a psychopath that sounds
interesting
uh so
yes you can take it again just don't lie
on it like don't manipulate the answers
look at the question and just answer the
question don't think about the answer
and then you can do it multiple times I
took it throughout my diet experience to
see if my personality traits changed
throughout you know coming off of
medication and getting healthy and the
only thing that changed is my politeness
level went way down and uh My
neuroticism Level went way down my
neuroticism level is it like
20
now things just don't really bother me
and my volatility used to be at 99.
but that was with psych meds and like
seven medications and Adderall
making me crazy so
yes you can take it again take it again
just don't lie on it
what do you think you would be doing for
a career if your dad wasn't Jordan
Peterson before
dad got famous I started writing a Blog
called don't eat that which is now it's
been transported over to liondiet.com
and I started getting invited onto
podcasts this is before I went on Rogan
to talk about diet my experience with
diet so I do think that even if Dad
wasn't my dad
I would have gone down the diet route
and tried to
educate people on what had helped me
that's where I would have started I
would have written my book because I'd
already been writing my book and I
really enjoyed podcasting so I may have
just started a podcast anyway so I might
be in a similar place I wouldn't be
launching Peterson Academy
you know if Dad wasn't my dad maybe I
would have finished my biomedical
science degree but I think I would have
just gone into the diet route instead
because that works for chronic disease I
think I would be in a similar place but
I wouldn't be launching Peterson Academy
and I wouldn't have you know I wouldn't
have as much of an audience for sure
um it would have just started in the
diet realm and kind of spread out from
there who is someone you really want to
have on the podcast no one is too
far-fetched Dave Portnoy he's so
entertaining he's such a dick he's
hilarious I want to have him on my
podcast
who else I'd like to have Andrew Schultz
on he said yes and now I'm putting in a
podcast so you're gonna look like a dick
if you don't come on Tom and Christina
Segura those are three good people
I would like to talk to him I mean
everyone wants to talk to Elon Musk
right so him what do you think of
psychedelics like psilocybin used more
to treat depression I think psychedelics
are so much safer than antidepressants
it's a great idea I would say it's a
great idea be careful
um trying to find a practitioner that
can walk you through your trip but I
found them extremely beneficial I think
that they can really
help open your eyes they can increase
your openness and be more open generally
speaking is a good thing so I'm a huge
proponent proponent of psychedelics now
don't do so many that you end up in a
loony bin specifically psilocybin okay
I'll end with this one because people
ask me this all the time does Scarlett
get to see her dad yes we co-parent so
she's with Andre half the time I think
that's good I have to run and do
something else I hope you guys enjoyed
this uh thank you for watching and I
guess subscribe if you want to see more
content like this and me not looking
like a fish
thanks husband so annoying I'm gonna
have to look at those clips
for
a long time
it's fine it's fixed it doesn't matter
it's cool okay ciao
[Music]